[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález la variante
delta del cobi 19 se ha propagado
rápidamente por el mundo de américa
latina' por supuesto no es la excepción
nuestra región también ha tenido que
hacer frente a la variante lambda varios
gobiernos de américa latina ahora
han avanzado en la apertura de la vida
social y también de la vida económica
pero no quieren dar marcha atrás porque
esto está buscando acelerar de pronto
las
intenciones políticas que puedan tener
algunos de los mandatarios de nuestra
región y pueda verse reflejado en votos
son favores políticos esto también se ha
visto reflejado en que hayan tenido que
acelerar las campañas de vacunación como
su mejor arma para poder combatir a la
variante delta les dejo un par de datos
fácticos para que entiendan de qué
estamos hablando el primer caso de la
variante de ésta fue registrado en india
en octubre del 2020
es dos veces o tal vez un poco menos
ahorita lo corrobora tenemos con
nuestros invitados dos veces más
contagiosa que la variante original que
se presentó en la ciudad de wuhan en
china que es la ciudad en donde se
originó este coronavirus está en la
lista de las variantes de preocupación
de la o ms y méxico costa rica brasil
ecuador y chile son los países que más
casos están registrando la variante
delta nuestra región
de hecho méxico está presentando un
largo pico de contagio por cuenta de
esta variante lo que ha llevado a que
este país rompa todos los récords en
cuanto a las cifras de fallecidos de
nuevos contagios de ocupación
hospitalaria según la odpe s el 94 por
ciento de los casos de contagio en
mexico ya corresponden a la variante
delta con una baja vacunación o digamos
una vacunación a media marcha y también
una muy mala infraestructura a que se
está exponiendo américa latina' estamos
en la antesala de un nuevo rebrote el
temor de que se tomen decisiones
necesarias y que genere mala imagen para
los gobiernos como por ejemplo volver a
un confinamiento cerrar otra vez la
economía enviar a los ciudadanos
nuevamente a sus casas esto ha llevado a
que las autoridades tal vez no estén
tomando las previsiones que necesiten
ante un pico que podría llegar en los
últimos meses de este año para la región
de américa latina
hacemos una comparación y américa del
sur por lo menos los países del cono sur
están registrando una baja de casos de
contagios y una baja en las
hospitalizaciones
de los muertos por supuesto pero méxico
como ya lo decíamos con un 94 por ciento
de los casos de delta nos recuerda que
la ola puede ser muy difícil de surfear
la variante delta una gran amenaza para
américa latina es el tema debate hoy en
france 24 y para analizar este tema
hemos invitado a anna céspedes directora
general de operaciones de international
aids vaccine initiative y también está
con nosotros
augusto de la torre él es director del
centro del centro de investigaciones
económicas de la universidad de las
américas en ecuador también es profesor
de la universidad de columbia y aquí en
el estudio de france 24 se encuentra con
nosotros el doctor carlos eduardo pérez
asesor científico de france 24 y también
médico infectólogo de la universidad
nacional de colombia
ustedes también hacen parte de esta
conversación les recuerdo que pueden
dejar todas sus preguntas y comentarios
a través de las redes sociales pueden
dejarlas en nuestras cuentas de facebook
de instagram y de twitter nos encuentra
como france24 guión bajo s mi cuenta
sant y luego dejen todos sus comentarios
con él el debate efe 24 pues tenemos ya
parte del contexto tenemos a los
invitados y quiero comenzar entonces con
anna preguntándole si estamos ante una
gran amenaza que no estamos tomando con
la seriedad pertinente en nuestros
gobiernos no están tomando la presencia
de la variante delta con suficiente
importancia previendo una posible ola en
unos meses
muy buenas noches santiago y muchas
gracias por la invitación yo creo que la
manera de ver esto es que estamos
abordando la pandemia de quabit como una
situación aguda cuando lo que se trata
es un poco de una maratón santiago se
trata de ir incrementando las cifras de
la curación se trata de ir viendo como
el virus evoluciona ahora tenemos la
variante delta hace meses hablábamos de
alfa y gamma esto va a ir evolucionando
entonces lo que tenemos que hacer es
aplicar todo el conjunto de medidas que
tenemos a nuestro alcance y explicar muy
bien a los ciudadanos que esto es una
situación que estamos manejando y que
tenemos que seguir manejando de manera
dinámica de modo que nadie se vea
sorprendido si habíamos dicho pues hay
que llevar ya se puede dejar de llevar
mascarillas y ahora no hay que volver a
llevarlas esto va a ser una situación
dinámica santiago durante los propios
meses y tenemos que ir explicando este
mensaje bien
augusto de la torre la ciudad de
washington su opinión estamos ante una
batalla que estamos talvez relajándonos
un poco abrimos la economía abrimos ya
la actividad social y pues esto nos
puede pasar una factura en los próximos
meses que piensa usted
yo creo que la santiago como estas
buenas noches me da la impresión a mí de
que estamos entrando en una nueva fase
en la que tenemos que entender que el
problema es un problema que va a estar
con nosotros por algún tiempo y que
debemos
optimizar la manera como lo enfrentamos
el mundo se como se está confrontando en
una pelea muerte con este coronavirus el
cual muta y se adapta y nos muestra
caras nuevas inusitadas y tenebrosas y
la ciencia nos da y la política pública
nos da criterios de cómo ir adaptándolo
de este problema
creo que no nos queda más que aceptar
que en los siguientes meses los
siguientes años vamos a tener que sentar
y tener tener que hacer camino al andar
y hay que tratar de hacer un camino al
andar' tratando de encontrar un balance
el más apropiado posible entre salvar
vidas evitar el congestionamiento de los
hospitales disminuir los contagios pero
al mismo tiempo evitar que la economía
vuelva contraerse y a caer como co
digamos en caída libre
este es un balance y una atención que
está renaciendo con nuevas modalidades
entre salvar vidas y salvar medios de
vida y ese es el camino que nos va a
tocar gestionar en los siguientes meses
lo cual pone otra vez el énfasis de la
importancia de la buena política pública
especialmente la de salud pública pero
no solo la de salud pública doctor pero
sus impresiones aquí en el estudio de
france 24 varios conceptos que crean con
nuestros invitados una maratón una
carrera contra el tiempo con contra el
coronavirus y vamos a tener que convivir
con este virus y esto nos va a llevar a
tener dinámicas diferentes en nuestra
vida pero ahorita estamos en una en un
momento en la región que ya lo
mencionaba yo en américa del sur están
bajando los casos están bajando las
hospitalizaciones y méxico nos está
mostrando que la variante delta no es
fácil de manejar y que hacerle frente le
está costando a méxico si nosotros
tenemos que muchas veces queremos pensar
con el deseo pero no con la realidad
nosotros deseamos
de que las olas no existieran de que las
variantes no tuvieran la repercusión
pero los virus no saben leer decretos no
saben de estadísticas los virus se
replican esta variante va a llegar a la
región y va a impactar nos que tan
importante hacer de impacto depende de
dos factores uno de la cobertura vacunal
y dos del comportamiento social que
hemos visto en la región que la
cobertura vacunal va a mediana marcha
pero va funcionando pero ese factor
social es un factor determinante por dos
razones la primera es porque la mayoría
de la economía es informal en donde las
personas tienen que salir a trabajar
porque la forma de subsidio es este tipo
de cosas no se hace procedente en estas
economías y lo segundo es porque muchos
gobiernos ya perdieron el control sobre
éstos llamaron confinamientos ya que
puede causar estallidos sociales como se
ha visto en algunos países de la región
y eso hace que esta forma que no que ya
sabemos que no con toda la pandemia sino
ralentiza para poder reaccionar con el
sistema de salud
en la región entonces nosotros estamos
hasta un gran desafío de una enfermedad
viral que es altamente transmisible no
solamente son dos veces puede ser hasta
58 veces más transmisible que el que la
enfermedad que conocíamos antes en una
región que todavía tiene infraestructura
muy pobre desde el punto vista
hospitalario y con coberturas vacunales
que todavía están en un proceso de
crecimiento pero no son suficientes
bueno ya tenemos el escenario que está
teniendo méxico que saca la vuelta de la
esquina también lo vemos en nueva
zelanda que también ha tenido que volver
a confinamiento entonces la gran apuesta
sería la vacunación en este caso la
vacunación sería el al bajo la manga
nosotros tenemos que saber que las
vacunas son parte de la solución pero la
solución también funciona en todo lo que
hemos aprendido en este tiempo muchas
más son las infecciones que se hacen en
admito reuniones que en las grandes
aglomeraciones y el comportamiento
social debe cambiarse nosotros no
podemos esperar una normalidad nosotros
tenemos que adaptarnos a lo que estamos
viviendo
esa adaptación hace que tengamos que
cumplir unos protocolos sociales claro
sin ninguna duda la vacunación es la
estrategia que más va a ayudar a
prevenir el impacto y nuestro
comportamiento
nuestra necesidad de acatar las
decisiones gubernamentales cuando sea
necesario y que haya una economía que no
se basa en informalidad sino en la
formalidad voy a ser parte de la
estrategia para mitigar el problema anna
en la ciudad de nueva york sus
impresiones sobre esta necesidad por lo
menos para la región de américa latina
de poder darle un poco más de velocidad
a la vacunación y ya sabemos la cantidad
de problemas que ha habido en los países
para acceder a las dosis para poder
acceder a los botes a través del
mecanismo kóvacs y también en países
como argentina bolivia nicaragua que se
quedaron sin segundas dosis de sputnik
efectivamente primero necesitamos
vacunas eficaces no todas tienen el
mismo nivel de eficacia y necesitamos
vacunas que alcancen al mayor porcentaje
posible de la población eeuu está
avanzando muy lento muy lentamente
estamos actualmente estancados en el 52%
europa está más avanzada pero
latinoamérica está por debajo del 30%
tenemos que subir esas cifras eso es muy
importante hay que también prevenir la
vacunación estamos viendo que no solo
que el virus muta sino que además muta
de una manera que lo hace de alguna
manera que las vacunas sean menos
resistentes es decir las vacunas siguen
protegiendo unos de la enfermedad grave
pero no nos protegen de la infección y
esto es muy importante porque eso
significa que personas vacunadas tienen
que seguir llevando mascarilla la vacuna
es una herramienta una herramienta
indispensable pero la mascarilla también
lo es y aunque es incómodo es una
herramienta muy eficaz que nos puede
permitir ir a trabajar tener pequeñas
reuniones y tener una vida social que de
alguna manera también reactiva la
economía por eso creo que es importante
destacar eso y el comportamiento social
junto con las vacunas nos va a permitir
ir manejando esta situación de una
manera que sea la nueva realidad no
volver a lo de antes pero una nueva
realidad que nos permita que economía y
salud vayan de la mano
doctor augusto de la torre o a gusto de
la torre si en la ciudad de washington
iba a preguntarle por la tercera dosis
que sigue siendo debatido en muchos
países de la región eeuu ya ha decidido
que lava inocular otros países como
chile uruguay ya están avanzando en ella
es necesario que los países entonces
sigan el ejemplo y aprueben la tercera
de dos y lo más rápido posible aun
teniendo dificultades para poder acceder
a estos lotes de vacunas
si dos puntos que vale la pena hacer
aquí hay una gran diferencia entre los
países
en el éxito en la velocidad de la
vacunación el caso reciente de mi país
en ecuador sugiere que no es imposible
acelerar el proceso de vacunación
ecuador paso por uno de los peores
períodos de afectación del coronavirus
en el año anterior y ahora es el país
que está casi en la cabeza del mundo en
la rapidez con la que está vacunando y
tenemos ya casi el 60 por ciento de la
población con doble vacunación
eso sugiere que la política pública
tiene un espacio más grande del que se
piensa para acelerar el proceso de
vacunación que a la larga la vacuna es
la mejor arma que tenemos en el momento
en la humanidad para combatir este este
virus entonces hay un tema de política
pública que tiene que ver con la
logística de la vacunación que tiene que
ir de la mano de lo que la ciencia
sugiere y obviamente me parece a mí que
el consenso de las ciencias que vamos a
tener que ir el reforzamientos de
vacunas que la vacunación inicial no va
a ser suficiente vamos a tener que
reforzar y vamos a tener que seguir
adaptándonos a esta situación con ayuda
de la ciencia y una buena política
pública eso me parece claro por otro
lado no podemos ignorar que el efecto
económico de lo que está pasando es
inmenso no sé este es un choque brutal a
la economía mundial y vamos a necesitar
pensar cómo vamos a reconstruir el
empleo la actividad económica normal en
los países que se quedaron con una
situación de gasto fiscal y de ansiedad
de dolor humano y de disparidades y de
inequidad es muy grandes entonces hacia
adelante tenemos el gran desafío de como
no solo adaptarnos para lidiar con este
terrible coronavirus sino de cómo ir
reconstruyendo el tejido de la economía
de tal forma que la nueva economía a la
que vayamos tenga cosas nuevas que
responden a los errores del pasado y ese
va a ser yo creo que el gran tema de la
meditación de la política pública de los
siguientes años
justo a la ronda la inversa continuó con
usted y le preguntó usted habla entonces
de la reconstrucción económica como un
factor necesario claramente así tiene
que ser para para que los países pues
puedan mantenerse y la sociedad también
pero qué hacer como reconstruir una
sociedad cómo reconstruir una economía
cuando estamos ante este escenario tan
complejo de incertidumbre porque hasta
hace unos meses américa latina estaba en
un pico en el peor de los momentos ahora
está respirando un poco pero está
haciendo frente a la variante de esta
que nos va a dar sorpresas a final de
año si siguen los contagios cómo van y
es completamente incierto
correcto la incertidumbre vuelve a subir
y eso se demuestra también en el
funcionamiento de los mercados
financieros la incertidumbre es muy
grande y eso dificulta las cosas pero
junto a la incertidumbre también tenemos
un problema de fatiga la población ya
está digamos con una ansiedad y una
fatiga muy grande del confinamiento y de
no poder volver a la vida normal
entonces la hay que irse adaptando poco
a poco para que podamos ir
reconstruyendo el tejido económico
superando la fatiga pero no exponiendo
nos innecesariamente a otras olas de
muertes adicionales obviamente esto es
como son las ondas del mar y la resaca
no es cierto primero viene una ola muy
grande y luego se apagó un poco viene el
segundo luna tercero ahora no sabemos
cuántas olas
el virus nos van a seguir atacando pero
no podemos desanimarnos tenemos que
seguir avanzando hacia adelante yo lo
que siento es que si bien esta segunda
ola de la variante delta nos está
golpeando de manera muy fuerte está
golpeando principalmente a la población
que no se ha vacunado dos todavía yo
creo que hay evidencia muy potente de
que el camino más importante hacia la
normalización de la situación económica
pasa por la vacunación puede ser que
necesitemos reforzamiento de la vacuna
del futuro pero obviamente necesitamos
superar el escollo inicial que es
asegurar que un porcentaje muy alto de
la población está vacunada por suerte en
américa latina' no tenemos esa psoe
ideológica que se ve en los países
avanzados en donde hay resistencia a la
vacuna y eso ha frenado muchísimo el
proceso de vacunación
me parece que américa latina' la
población está más abierta a seguir el
consejo de la ciencia y de la plática
pública
anna le pregunto a ustedes la ciudad de
nueva york sobre el acceso a las vacunas
precisamente lo estaba mencionando
augusto el acceso a la vacuna no ha sido
equitativo no ha sido fácil ha requerido
pulso económico a colaboración
internacional un mecanismo creado que no
ha dado el resultado esperado el acceso
de cara a una posible ola de la variante
delta para américa latina puede ser aún
más difícil del que ya tuvimos en picos
anteriores como lo vio usted
bueno puede ser más difícil pero creo
que hay que ser optimistas porque
tenemos más de 8 vacunas aprobadas está
incrementándose multiplicándose de hasta
10 veces la capacidad productiva es
decir y hay países como por ejemplo
estados unidos donde hay un exceso de
demanda están caducando vacunas y se
está incluso incentivando desde hace ya
meses para que la población se vacune a
y como decía el doctor anterior una una
resistencia a vacunarse que que
realmente cuesta cuesta entender y que
requiere mucha educación sanitaria
afortunadamente latinoamericano está de
esa situación españa por ejemplo tampoco
es tan es así la gente entiende muy bien
la ciencia sabe que hay que respetar los
resultados y que se ha seguido el
proceso yo creo que la problemática aquí
y santiago que se plantea es que estamos
abordando esta crisis mundial de una
enfermedad infecciosa con una visión
local el virus se hace resistente no le
importa en qué país la variante delta
surgen india se hace resistente unas
tasas de vacunación muy bajas y a día de
hoy es casi el 98 por ciento de las
nuevas infecciones en eeuu necesitamos
una cobertura mínima a nivel mundial y
en la llamada que ha hecho la
organización mundial de la salud de
antes de una tercera dosis por favor
vacunemos a todo el mundo creo que es
una ya muy importante hay que asegurar
ese acceso yo soy optimista que en
latinoamérica se está incrementando el
acceso a la vacunación y está subiendo
muy rápido
doctor aquí en el estudio de france 24
esto pone en la mesa de debate si la
vacunación debe ser obligatoria o no
independiente que los países pueden
acceder fácilmente a ella yo creo que
hay un punto interesante
latinoamérica ciertamente tiene menos
problema con los grupos antivacunas con
este tipo de resistencias que hay hacia
la vacuna basadas en algunas
percepciones sobre la seguridad de ellas
sin embargo el problema entonces de
asimetría nosotros ya prácticamente
nuestra política de salud pública es una
política de súplica para que las vacunas
que hemos tenido recientemente son
vacunas donadas
definitivamente la estrategia coach no
funcionó no funciona ya le hemos dado un
tiempo de más de un año de unos meses
para que tuviéramos vacunas a través de
ese mecanismo y no funcionan los
acuerdos bilaterales son acuerdos que
han hecho los gobiernos en donde las
entregas de las vacunas son a
cuentagotas y hay retrasos en las
segundas y terceras dosis
e imprimir la obligatoriedad es una de
las decisiones que tomarse y que se
hacer con la sensatez de que la
vacunación nos permite la reactivación
hacia nuestra vida social hacia la
economía y tiene que ser importante que
ese consenso social se llegue a que la
vacunación sea una herramienta
obligatoria y en caso de no serlo que
asegure que la persona que no se vacuna
no nos infecte haciéndose pruebas de
tamizaje frecuentemente
las estrategias de vacunación dependen
de una cosa no es de la buena voluntad
sino de que existan las vacunas y
nosotros hemos visto que nuestros países
tienen las vacunas tenemos la
disposición pero el recurso sigue siendo
limitado y básicamente estamos
dependientes de las donaciones de que lo
que sobra nos puedan usar porque no
tenemos ni la capacidad productiva y si
tenemos la capacidad intelectual para
poderlo hacer pero no tenemos la
infraestructura para organizarnos y
hacerlas nosotros mismos las vacunas
en el doctor pérez habla de la donación
de las vacunas ustedes lo han mencionado
también a lo largo del programa pero qué
impresión tiene usted de esta
solidaridad mundial
porque vimos algunos países que
intentaron acaparar la mayor cantidad de
vacunas posibles y hay muchos países
donde ni siquiera han empezado el plan
de vacunación y la llevamos un año y
medio poco más de crisis sanitaria a
nivel internacional como evalúa usted
está en solidaridad esto pasa más que
simplemente donar lotes de vacunas pasa
más que simplemente ceder su turno de
compra de un lote a otro país que lo
necesita como lo evalúa usted bueno no
ha habido solidaridad creo que ese es el
resumen tenemos países donde las tasas
de vacunación es un 1 por ciento países
con bajos recursos otro grupo de países
con medios bajos un 15% países con
medios altos un 30 y los países con
altos recursos están el 60 por ciento
básicamente dime tu poder dime tu tasa
de vacunación y que adivinar el poder
adquisitivo que tienes en esta pandemia
a la cámara internacional de comercio
estableció un indicador que decía que
las donaciones por cada euro dólar que
se dona se se tendría un retorno de la
inversión de hasta 166 veces en cuanto a
retorno de la economía global si los
países con más recursos donasen recursos
a los que no los tienen para hacer esa
compra tendrían un retorno de 166 veces
y se ahorraría el doble de muertes con
la una distribución equitativa de
vacunas se hubiera ahorrado el doble de
muertes pero no ha habido equidad
santiago esa es la manera de resumir lo
hemos abordado esta campaña con una
visión totalmente nacionalista a nivel
mundial en los países que no tenían la
capacidad económica o la capacidad la
infraestructura para fabricar vacunas y
como bien dice no sólo es el
conocimiento necesito las plantas de
instalación disponibles y las materias
primas pues esos países se han visto
rezagados en la compra de vacuna y
kóvacs no ha funcionado realmente porque
no ha tenido financiación kóvacs ha
estado lanzando llamadas a conseguir
financiación y no ha conseguido la
financiación que se necesitaba para en
el mercado mundial y ese es el panorama
de muchos países de américa latina que
le apostaron al mecanismo kóvacs para
abastecerse de vacunas acaso paraguay y
empezó la vacunación en la región y
luego ellos se quedaron rezagados porque
no tenían cómo acceder de manera directa
el gobierno paraguayo a las
farmacéuticas para poder adquirir sus
lotes y les tocó esperar hasta que
kóvacs se acordará de ellos y les
donaron primer lote muchos países están
así y bueno el caso de ti pues es el más
evidente de todos en medio de la
tragedia también de el terremoto augusto
él le pregunto a aquí con juguemos
varias cosas y todo esto lo enfocó en el
sentido de que en unos meses podemos
estar viendo un pico de contagio por la
variante delta en nuestra región puede
haber voluntad política un plan público
de vacunación que usted lo mencionaba
varias veces que ya ha demostrado que
funcione
pero las farmacéuticas están quedando
mal también vemos el caso del instituto
gamma leia de rusia que dejó
argentina-bolivia de varios países de la
región sin las segundas dosis es
peligroso espaciar estas dosis es
peligroso comprometerse con estas
farmacéuticas que no sabemos si el día
de mañana nos van a cumplir con los
lotes
augusto
ahora sí lo vamos a muchas gracias
discúlpame
quería ser el punto de que la vacuna es
un bien público global
un bien público no puede ser producido
eficientemente por el mercado y si se
deja la libre voluntad de las de los
individuos y de las empresas y de los
farmacéuticos requiere de coordinación y
esa coordinación solo pueden proveer los
estados entonces hemos tenido digamos
una escasez de coordinación de política
pública global
este es el tema de la vacuna es tan
importante como bien público que no se
le puede poner un precio y no debe
depender de la capacidad de compra que
tienen las personas a la larga todos
estaremos bien cuando todos estén
vacunados y nadie estará bien mientras
no estén todos vacunados en un sentido
estadísticamente importante entonces
tratándose de un bien público no puede
dejarse que funcione solo la voluntad de
las fuerzas del mercado y decisiones de
empresas individuales o de países
individuales nos ha faltado coordinación
global la coordinación global no sucede
espontáneamente requiere que haya
liderazgo y nos ha faltado liderazgo de
los grandes países que son más ricos que
son más grandes son más influyentes para
convertir esto en una cruzada global el
mismo fenómeno lo confrontamos cuando
hablamos del calentamiento global no lo
podemos resolver a nivel individual y de
mercados necesitamos políticas públicas
coordinadas a nivel global eso nos ha
faltado en el mundo pero el hecho de que
haya habido deficiencia de política
pública global para coordinarnos y
proveer este bien público que es la
vacuna
contradice el otro hecho que también ha
habido hay muchas deficiencias en la
política de salud pública de los países
individuales y algunos países que tenían
muy mal muy mal digamos protocolos de
salud pública ha mejorado mucho es el
caso de ecuador y otros no han logrado
darle suficiente tracción a la logística
de la vacunación y de la distribución de
las vacunas entonces hay de parte y
parte los problemas a nivel nacional de
la calidad de los servicios de salud
pública y grandes problemas de a nivel
global de coordinación vamos a tener que
ir superando todo esto porque como
decíamos antes vamos a tener que
convivir con este virus hasta que sea un
virus que se parece a la gripe y que no
nos ve no nos impida tener una vida
normal yo creo que el potencial está ahí
no hay que desanimarse se entiende a la
fatiga se entiende la incertidumbre pero
la voluntad de sobrevivencia del globo
del planeta tiene que ser digamos de la
guía general para seguir avanzando
añade unos datos a lo que estaba
hablando poniendo como ejemplo la
situación de argentina y de otros países
de la región argentina allí 6 puntos 6
millones de personas se quedaron
esperando una segunda dosis de la vacuna
sputnik de guatemala pues se cansó a
esperar un lote de vacunas que había
pedido y canceló la mitad de un contrato
de 16 millones de dosis y panamá
simplemente se dio cuenta que rusia que
el instituto gamal ella no iba a
cumplirle con esa entrega de dosis y
terminó cancelando un contrato de 3
millones de dosis que habían cargado
hasta este laboratorio ruso doctor
pregunta médica tal vez ya lo hemos
conversado en nuestro programa de los
viernes pero está esto genera problemas
en el plan de vacunación la demora en
las entregas de las vacunas y genera
problemas en el suministro de las dosis
hay problemas para los pacientes y si
tienen más espaciadas las dosis de las
vacunas por encima de los días que
estipulan las reglas que pueden tener
cada una de las vacunas en general lo
que hemos visto es que es es pasear las
vacunas no pierden su efectividad antes
se habla de los 21 días estrictos pero
ya en algunos países se aplica a 12
semanas como se hace en europa las
vacunas rn a teniendo mejores resultados
y digamos que esa prolongación
no afecta tanto el proceso de vacunación
pero si en algo muy importante que la
ansiedad porque todos queremos estar
protegidos y limitar esa segunda dosis
lo que trae es una ansiedad generalizada
mayor inestabilidad y mayor desconfianza
y lo que estamos viendo es esa pandemia
de la desconfianza hacia el sistema
público incluso se traslada a las
vacunas y eso es sentimiento de
desconfianza que trae la irregularidad
del suministro pues trae desconcierto y
eso es un gran problema para la
vacunación desde el punto vista
estrictamente médico los intervalos no
se pierde la eficacia aunque no se deben
cumplir las pautas como están
establecidas prolongarlas las segundas
dosis puede que no impacte mucho el
protocolo
árbol el desconcierto la desconfianza y
la depresión que trae no cumplir lo
prometido realmente es otro problema que
tenemos que volver a afrontar que ese es
un escenario muy posible que podamos
tener en unos meses y la variante del
está sigue avanzando en nuestra región y
genere muchos más casos y todavía hay
mucha gente que está esperando para
poderse vacunar aunque hay algunos
países han habilitado también la
vacunación para adolescentes y tienen un
rango amplio de su población se lo está
acabando ya el tiempo quiero llegar ya
entonces al punto de las conclusiones
augusto en la ciudad de washington
sus conclusiones de lo que va a
enfrentar entonces américa latina frente
a la variante del está muy puntual
tenemos que estar preparados para una
segunda ola pero tenemos que hacerlo de
tal forma que la segunda ola que es la
variante delta tenga efectos más
benignos sobre el ritmo de
hospitalización y sobre las muertes
afortunadamente eso sí se está
observando pese a que hay incidencia
creciente de contagios a través de la
variante delta el número de fallecidos y
de hospitalización en los países están
mejor vacunados no ha ido aumentando
pero también tenemos que ser optimistas
ya vemos que en eeuu incluso con los
problemas de enormes que tiene de
superar las resistencias a la vacunación
la economía y empieza a recuperarse
esperes a recuperarse a un ritmo
bastante potente entonces yo creo que
hay que hay que manejarse con estas
adversidades de una segunda ola sin
perder el optimismo de que nuestras
economías van a regenerarse necesitan
reconstruirla necesitan de estarse
optimismo es la conclusión de augusto
ana en la ciudad de nueva york sus
conclusiones de lo que podemos enfrentar
en nuestra región a qué nos estamos
enfrentando en este momento ya
pues estamos enfrentándonos a un largo
plazo más largo de lo que nos gustaría
desafortunadamente en el que podemos
influir mucho con nuestras medidas la
mascarilla la mascarilla aunque estemos
vacunados nos estamos enfrentando a la
necesidad probablemente de tener que
tener una tercera dosis o incluso dosis
de recuerdo a menudo probablemente
pronto los niños hay que vacunar les
pronto mujeres embarazadas también y
sobre todo optimismo santiago porque
sube el sistema inmunitario aumenta
mejoran las defensas y tenemos vacunas
tenemos soluciones es un largo plazo hay
que estar preparados pero optimistas y
optimistas y ser un poco cautelosos
también y tener un poco de paciencia que
esto tal vez nos ha faltado doctor pero
lo dejo para el cierre del programa para
la conclusión final sus impresiones de
lo que vamos a estar viviendo en este
escenario en este posible escenario que
nos tenemos que preparar yo pienso que
la gran conclusión es que las vacunas
van a frenar la expansión de estas
variante es la que venga y la vacuna es
la mejor estrategia para contener la
pandemia pero no hay vacuna para la
arrogancia para la desigualdad para la
asimetría y sobre todo para el egoísmo
el llamado la solidaridad es que no
importa si tenemos 23 ó 50 vacunas cada
uno de nosotros es que si no se vacuna
los que están al lado de nada servir la
vacuna
por eso equidad y ahí simetría social
son parte de la solución también doctor
muchas gracias por esa reflexión final a
ustedes muchas gracias también por
habernos acompañado a nuestros invitados
gracias por haber estado con nosotros
sigan con france24
[Música]